my name is Liam Reeves I'm a cosplayer
and I've been doing this for the last 24
years today we are blowing a bell jar
for a reproduction of an early 18th
century vacuum pump initially we gather
the glass from the furnace using what's
called a blowing iron which is
essentially a stainless steel tube
and then we shape the glass using wooden
blocks and newspaper we soaked that in
water the the burning action of the
glass creates a carbon layer and then
the water in the newspaper turns into
steam and creates a cushioning layer so
you can shape the glass but because it's
malleable you can it's much more
versatile and you can use it to create
shapes and do lots of different things
the gloss blow then blows down the tube
to introduce air into the glass to
inflate here you use the air itself but
then usually in conjunction with
centrifugal force in gravity and other
shaping tools included in the newspaper
to create shapes and push the glass in
different directions in the middle of
the process I create a bottleneck on the
end of the bowl of the jar to do that I
use basically oversized steel tweezers
and you pinch the glass and then stretch
a neck part out
the glass cools down very rapidly so it
goes from being very liquid to being act
like solid you know I've quite a short
period of time so part of being a glass
barrier is being able to work the glass
in different ways at different stages so
glass playing is very much a two-person
activity you can do a certain amount on
your own but it really does need two
people clause playing essentially hasn't
really changed at all in a thousand
years it's essentially the same process
that it was then the only difference
really is that now we use electronic
controllers to measure of the
temperature and we use gas to fire the
furnace it's a it's a very difficult
craft to learn it takes six years to
learn the basics and twelve to be a
master it can be extremely frustrating
it can be punishingly hot at the same
time it's all extremely addictive it can
be very very good fun it can be very
satisfying it's all of those really
[Music]
[Music]